Sam Donald third overall pick in the
2018 draft the Jets traded up to get him
AFC Offensive Player of the Week against
the Cowboys in week six then comes week
seven and it's a disaster
then comes the controversy regarding the
miked up audio of him saying that he was
seeing ghost Chris look setting aside
the controversy because I really do
think the Jets reaction to it made it a
bigger deal than it needed to be yes
what does to explain what it means to
see ghosts and how you get to the point
as a quarterback where you're not is it
something you're always dealing with or
is it just something that you can grow
out of do you minimize it how do you get
from the point where you're seeing goes
to the point where you're not well this
is a you know a very rare occurrence
even for even a young quarterback and
you know seeing ghost is just code word
for I'm flustered and they got me seeing
things that aren't real and things that
are that are real I'm not seeing them
clearly and that's basically what that
is there and that's what New England did
to them you know New England figured out
that hmm in obvious passing situations
when the New York Jets are in shotgun
and you know this field is kind of
spread Bill Belichick through his study
said their blitz pickups and what they
do to adjust to the Blitz is not up to
par and I'm going to expose this not
only because Adam GaSe doesn't have
maybe the correct plan with some of
these formations and things like that
Sam Donald doesn't know where to go with
the ball either and when he's talking
about ghosts you know there was some
times in the game where okay early on
they bring the blitzes and he throws
interceptions right trying to get the
ball of his hand in a hurry to get beat
the Blitz then as the game goes on they
faked the blitzes and yet he was
throwing the ball like oh man I have
pressure around me but they had faked
the Blitz there was nobody there and
that's why he throws in the ball down
the field and you're like where is that
ball going and you know it's right into
the defenders hands because he wasn't
sure what he was seeing so his mind was
all over the place we talked about like
game speed slowing down right I bet you
that game was like in fast forward and
like times three the other night versus
am darling he was going oh my gosh am i
protected Oh what coverage is it oh gosh
I think I'm protect
let me look one more time wait what's
the coverage downfield Oh interception
and that's basically what it means by
seeing goes I had it happen to me
against the Baltimore Ravens in 2006
Mike with the bray lewis and that team
you know they just i got in that game
through some interceptions they were
good and messed up some things that were
things i would never mess up like you
know protection calls and idea the right
guy in the run game or whatever but
because i had been flustered by their
physicality their disguises and things
like that i messed up some things that i
would never mess up because i was
overthinking and worried about too many
different things yeah and i guess that
that really is the corollary here the
game slows down and you stop seeing
ghosts so when you get to the point
where you are in that that zone where
you understand what's happening and it
feels like you can master the speed of
the game you've gotten accustomed to it
that's when you stop freaking out and
thinking that you see things that you
don't see because that's the human
reaction that's what your brain does
yeah when you feel that frustration when
you feel flustered when you feel like
you're confused by everything that's
happening around you right that's
basically what it is and and again this
might not be the last time he sees
ghosts because there's been great great
like NFL Hall of Famers who have gotten
the middle of their career and gone
still through moments where they saw
ghosts I mean you know you talk about
like Aaron Rodgers in Denver a few years
ago remember with that great Denver
defense I bet you he was seeing ghosts
in that game the 2007 Super Bowl with
Steve spagnolo doing all these different
things for Tom Brady there's moments and
plays in that game where Brady he's
gonna go oh I should have just hit that
guy or why did I get the ball out of my
hands so quickly well why because you
were confused a few times I some blitzes
you never saw them bring all year in
your study or Strahan had beaten people
man-to-man and you're thinking your
internal clocks off so it is something
that happens it just happened on a big
stage and because he's young it's
snowballed into something really
gigantic and it just made it worse and
worse
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports